[Musique]
l'après midi commence par un spectacle
de magie le jeune public est captivé
mais les garçons de la source en sorte
avec une légère frustration est élu
puisqu'il nous a pas interrogés
il laisse même pas passé nous laissez
pas parler place à la visite du château
pour la douzaine de sourds siens à
l'initiative de l'opération les trois f1
des bailleurs sociaux de la source
l'organisme a sollicité les éducateurs
de l'escale association qui intervient
auprès de centaines d'enfants ça ce sont
des enfants qui font partie de
l'animation de rue dont des enfants
qu'on touche dans le cadre de cette
action notamment des enfants qui ne sont
pris en charge par aucune structure et
les amener ici c'est un petit peu les
leur faire découvrir autre chose parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude de sortir du
quartier
c'est une manière aussi de les avoir pas
dans les parties communes ni dans les
espaces extérieurs leur montrer autre
chose
après vous restez à ma disposition j'ai
des choses à vous dire à cette partie
aux portes de l'édifice du 16e siècle
les visiteurs sont accueillis par
barnabé est cette fois leur
participation est requise et encourager
les internautes à il est gravement
malade à cause du froid
et là il ya huit ans que je peins de
noël il nous a demandé d'aller dans
plusieurs états pour récupérer le cam en
île-de le panel des écuries la quête
même les enfants dans les différentes
pièces du château en quête d'un disent
ils sont invités à écouter observer
toucher sentir une odeur de fruits sel
épices et par la tribu les sens et sa
santé pourquoi c'est bien parce qu'il ya
des luttes un atout c'est mieux que la
magie pourquoi on va trouver des traits
qu'on découvre la beauté de ce château
impliqués et curieux le pari est réussi
dernière étape une photo souvenir de la
visite la première visite d'un château
pour certains de ses enfants